Born
and growing up in New York City,
automatically you have first a little
uberous
by definition because there's nothing
beyond New York City.
Though I have traveled the world and
there are great cities,
but I think most important,
the diversity of New York City,
the diversity of people,
diversity of ideas,
diversity of foods,
music experiences automatically forces a
certain amount of your boundaries,
uh,
to come down because you meet,
meet people and have these experiences
that are so different from whatever
experiences you grew up.
I grew up in a traditional Jewish home,
wound up going to Columbia University,
and,
and literally all of a sudden,
an entire world was there.
I was living on 116th street and,
and there were more types of food.
One could have in a five,
six,
seven block radius,
then one could have in whole other
cities in the world.
And so yet alone,
all the different kinds of people in the
different sounds and,
and the different smells.
And,
and I think what that does is it opens
up,
um,
but that,
yeah.